[Musique]
cérémonie émouvante ce samedi à
carrières sous poissy un square a été
renommé au nom de clarissa jean-philippe
la policière tuée à montrouge paramédics
coulibaly et lui famille et riverains
sont venus lui rendre un dernier hommage
c'est très important comme ça on oublie
pas arrêt dans les mémoires et c'était à
lui de beaux discours et c'est vraiment
touchant il est et restera dans notre
coeur est un grand vide il ya un grand
vide pour ça c'était une collègue une
amie et au grand vide ils ont
fait de belles choses pour clarisse ans
elle serait contente elle est contente
immense l'air de jeu se situe au pied de
l'immeuble où vivait la jeune policière
dont le quartier des bords de seine un
endroit qu'elle appréciait tout
particulièrement la mère de la jeune
fille qui a fait le déplacement de la
martinique avec son fils se souvient
comme elle habitait là et puis c'est
l'heure de l'itie qu'elle faisait son
footing elle faisait tout elle venait
pour se ressourcer de la martinique elle
voit pas encore qu'elle voyait pas ma
cousine et moi on est donné avec elle et
nous emmener partout on a vécu là je
vois qu'ils ont fait ça c'est comme si
je revois ma fille assise au parc
un an après sa disparition tragique le
meurtre de clarissa dans l'exercice de
ses fonctions
relance le débat sur l'armement des
policiers municipaux
une mesure annoncée par françois
hollande quelques jours après les
attentats du 13 novembre
aujourd'hui on a des terroristes qui
sont prêts à tuer tuer de manière
gratuite avec des armes de guerre donc
forcément a minima il faut armer nos
policiers il était temps que le pouvoir
politique donne cet ordre
clarissa jean-philippe fait partie des
148 victimes du terrorisme qui ont
trouvé la mort en 2015 sur le sol
français
[Musique]